good evening everyone
thank you for joining us
for those of you who don't already know
me i'm lynn cooley the dean of the
graduate school of arts and sciences
i'm very pleased to welcome you to our
first presentation in a series of
conversations with yale graduate school
alumni
sponsored by the graduate school and its
alumni board
this series called perspectives is meant
to
bridge our alumni and student
communities sharing alumni experiences
and insights as both models for success
and to open opportunities for alumni and
students to connect
i have ambitious goals for transforming
and evolving yale's approach to doctoral
education
as well as plans to strengthen and build
our alumni community
to connect our faculty administrators
and students more frequently and to help
ignite these connections in support of
our students
i look forward to using what we learned
from this series to think about how we
can continue to improve graduate student
experiences experiences for all students
so today we will be joined by charles d
brown ii
phd alumnus from the department of
physics
as well as ja chen
who is our vice chair of the graduate
school alumni board
and matthew taniko assistant dean for
graduate student life in the graduate
school
we hope that you will enjoy this
conversation about charles's scholarship
and the lessons he has learned from his
days as a graduate student at yale
i'm really glad to have graduate
students alumni and faculty and old
friends of charles tuning in from around
the world
and i hope you will enjoy the
conversation
hi everyone good evening my name is
matthew tanako and as lynn mentioned i'm
the assistant dean for graduate student
life here at yale
before we get started i want to share a
few housekeeping items with you
we'll be recording this webinar and
we'll share the recording after the
conversation
we're also offering closed captioning
and you can control that via the button
on the bottom of your screen
in the second half of the session we'll
be saving some time for questions and
answers
many graduate students and alumni have
submitted questions in advance but we
also hope that you'll enter additional
questions using the q a feature at the
bottom of your screen
i'll be moderating this discussion with
my fellow alum ja chen vice chair of the
graduate school alumni association board
who is a yale gsas alumni from the
department of physics i'll rely on her
for the technical background as a
humanist
now i'm delighted to introduce charles d
brown ii
charles received his phd in physics from
yale in 2019 and is currently a national
academy of science engineering and
medicine ford foundation postdoctoral
fellow in the ultra cold atomic physics
group in the department of physics at
the university of california berkeley
as well as co-founder and co-lead
organizer of
black and physics week a week dedicated
to celebrating the historical
contributions of black physicists
welcome ja and charles
thank you very much matthew um thank you
dingling cooley
thank you for this opportunity so um
i am the vice chair of the graduate
school alumni board and i'm delighted to
have this opportunity to post a first
question to our guest charles
charles i noticed actually
last week you gave a talk at our physics
club
about a
complex topic of lattice trapped quantum
gas so
very interesting i wonder whether the
talk was virtual in person or it's a
hybridization of
giving a virtual conference
on campus so but um we'd like to ask you
about your research in grad school and
um your work in current role and and how
that work evolved
i'm happy to talk about that uh but
first thank you very much for having me
here i'm very excited to have this
opportunity to talk with you all about a
series of very important uh topics to me
um but to the research so
as a phd student i worked in a field
called optimum mechanics opto referring
to light mechanics referring to
some sort of oscillatory motion of an
object in the field where the light or
in the area where the light exists
so it turns out that if you can confine
some amount of light to some geometry
and you can oscillate some object within
it you can produce an interaction
between the light and the mechanical
object that's oscillating in a way where
they sort of mutually affect each
other's behavior
it turns out that you can use that
system to do potentially to do some very
technologically interesting things for
example do networking between different
kinds of
devices
perhaps
quantum computing devices uh when they
exist in the future and you need to sort
of have them talk to each other an
optomechanical platform is a it's an
interesting one to do that sort of work
it also turns out that
if you want to do something like
test the limits of quantum mechanics if
you want to see
sort of how big a mechanical object can
be a massive object can be and still
exhibit quantum behavior sort of
you know almost wacky physics behavior
that you don't see
in your normal life on normal length
scales an optomechanical system is an
interesting one to use
to try to you know really understand
what is the limits of the size of a
system in which you can see quantum
mechanics
and so
in my phd
i did things like
um have light
interact with density fluctuations in a
really special kind of lip that was sort
of half of my time in grad school the
other time the other half of my time in
grad school was building a new very
interesting system
which involved levitating um a drop of
superfluid liquid healing this is a very
interesting state of matter that flows
with zero viscosity
you can use very powerful magnetic
magnetic fields to levitate that liquid
and you can shine lasers on it
where some of the light will get trapped
inside of the drop and that light will
interact with the drops vibrations so
now you have a new kind of
optomechanical system that's well
isolated from its environment and so
well positioned to
eventually study some interesting
quantum physics phenomena
now as a post-doc might do something
quite different
but still quantum mechanics quantum
physics is at the heart of what i study
so to sort of introduce this it's useful
to think about solid materials
a solid say a crystal
um it is a periodic arrangement of
ions
where electrons hop back and forth
between the different positions of the
ions
the hopping of those electrons around
the material determines a lot of the
materials properties
now you can make a lattice completely
out of light this is what i do now
and you can make atoms really really
cold you can throw those atoms into that
lattice made of white and those atoms
will hop around the lattice
and it turns out that this platform is a
nice system to sort of simulate a real
solid crystal
but
our system is on a larger scale it's
easier to image
everything is slowed down and more
easily measurable with our current
technology and so we can use these sort
of quantum simulation experiments to
gain insight into the physics the
quantum physics of materials in a way
that is difficult for people that use
that study this sort of physics
in solid materials and it's all sort of
a platform to start learning about how
when you have a large system with many
interacting particles where quantum
mechanics is important sort of how does
the system behave there's lots of open
and very interesting questions there and
so now i'm geared towards trying to
address those sorts of questions
very fascinating charles wow
matthew what do you think
yeah no thank you sorry
problems that we have
um no that was amazing trolls can you
talk a little bit about the sort of move
that you've made
in your own career and
i want to talk a little bit about the
hashtag black and physics week that you
started
some of our fellow alumni association
board members actually came across your
article which is part of the reason why
we wanted to bring you um to be in
conversation with us this evening um and
you've written in um your
somewhat scholarly work i would still
call it that um you're about your own
experiences with bias and anti-blackness
within the academy um and so as a result
of that uh those experiences you started
hashtag black and physics can you tell
us a little bit more about the
initiative but also about some of those
experiences that you felt both as a
graduate student and in your current
role as a as a postdoc but more
generally as a physicist
yeah absolutely um so i actually have a
lot to say here as you might imagine um
but i think
i can sort of quickly sum up my
experiences um in the academy
with the idea that um as i read as i
wrote in the
physics of the article you're
referencing disentangling anti-blackness
from physics
many of my experiences as a student
involved people who had a hard time
understanding that i was part of the
intellectual community
and so it was often the case that i was
sort of
thought to not belong in certain spaces
and that made for very difficult
interactions and it was sort of the
build up of this over over years that
was very difficult and you know this is
not a problem you meet to yale this is a
problem that sort of happens
when
you have a very small number of people
that look like me
in a space where
the people who make up the majority of
the institution aren't used to seeing
people like me around or maybe haven't
even had many previous experiences
interacting with
um
uh say black people well that was
surprising uh let alone uh in an
intellectual capacity so i think that
has summed up many of my experiences as
a student at yale and it has also
uh you know played a part in some of my
experiences as a postdoc here um at
berkeley
so
let me address uh black in physics
um
so
you know i guess the question is sort of
why did it come about uh well
uh black in physics was was born during
a moment of chaos as a way for the
community of black physicists to come
together and gain a foothold as the
world around us seem to be on shaky
ground
now another organization the national
society of black physicists started in
an important aspect of this community
building work and it's been doing so for
decades but
on our side we wanted to
sort of further build such a community
based on
modern social media tools that grant a
new level of global access and allow for
new ways for distant individuals to
engage and remain engaged with each
other
you know part of our goal with black and
physics is to
paint a more complete picture of what a
physicist looks like unfortunately only
about three percent of physics bachelors
go to black physicists and only two
percent of phds go to black physicists
this necessarily means that the number
of black physicists in lab directorship
roles be they in academia or industry is
small
and it was just last year
uh in the entire multi-century history
of u.s higher education that we crossed
the threshold of 100
u.s born african-american women having
attained phds
in physics or astronomy
and so you know even though our numbers
are small uh black physicists have
played an important role in the history
of physics whether it be their roles in
as sort of research associates in labs
say students or for post-docs or their
equivalent or as principal investigators
uh directing research labs
and it turns out that yale has an
important role in this history right the
first black american to receive a phd
in the us was a man by the name of
edward boucher and it was awarded in
physics by yale in i believe 1876
with its history as a leader in many
fields its great influence you know not
only in the academic sphere but but also
in the larger societal sphere you know
yale has given yale is given its uh its
great resources well positioned to truly
lead and attracting and importantly
retaining diverse talent that'll level
the playing field um
so yeah with with black and physics uh
we're not only shining a light on the
important contributions of these
physicists by for example uh leading
wikipedia editing campaigns that produce
pages for accomplished scientists who
previously either had no page or whose
page was only sparsely populated but we
also provide a microphone to amplify the
voices of these physicists through our
you know widely read highly visible
series of publications that appear both
in physics today and physics world
magazines which have global reach
um you know at this point we've reached
a point where we've made it difficult to
not see all of the many talented black
physicists who are highly qualified to
hold principal investigative roles such
as professorships or staff scientist
positions at national labs or
research team leads in industry
and we've aided in making it quite clear
that the talent exists and where to find
it the next step is to truly value black
physicist contributions and to
understand that
in order to continue to grow and be
better physics as a as a discipline must
make space um
healthy and welcoming space a supportive
and respectful space for black
physicists so that not only can the
discipline reap the benefits of our much
needed perspective but also so that
black physicists can reap the
socio-economic benefit of having highly
valuable technical knowledge in a highly
tech driven society that constantly
faces moral dilemmas that affect many
different groups of people
but typically only have one group of
people making the decisions
often with an unacceptably low
understanding of how people from
different groups are affected with those
decisions
i know that was sort of
a long skill but that's that's my take
on black and physics and sort of that is
why we are doing what we are doing and
why our work is important
i really appreciate that
and can
can you speak a little bit to the way in
which there's pressure
both from within and beyond the academy
around this um i i'm not 100 sure about
your own experiences with this but you
know i know for graduate students who
are currently at yale there's a lot of
thought into whether or not you stay
within the academy and you become a
faculty member or to leave the academy
and has that played a role at all um or
your
um has lack in physics helped you
navigate the sort of career trajectory
that you've decided to pursue
yeah so i think i think black and
physics has helped me navigate that
my career trajectory before black and
physics it was the national society of
black physicists
and you know
when i first started graduate school i
had gone i had decided to go to graduate
school because i said to myself i want
to work as a professional physicist and
typically in order to do professional
physicist work you would have a phd and
so i found myself in grad school
throughout my grad school process
especially given the difficulties
especially given you know my difficulty
with
uh
you know having a lot of messaging that
suggested that i didn't belong in
physics physics i sort of went through
this very windy roller coaster of i need
to get out of here asap and you know i
need to be a part of academia and not
only do excellent physics but also like
really take part in shepherding the
future of the academy right there's a
very windy path of humans too and when i
first went to the national society of
black physicist conference
uh which meant yuri actually i sort of
made happen
um that was my first time seeing so many
black scientists so many black
physicists uh that was my first time
meeting any and that was a completely
like life-changing experience for me
and so that was something that really
like sort of put it in my mind and heart
that this physics thing is something
that i could really do and i think that
my work with black and physics has sort
of
further strengthened that that feeling
in my mind right so now i'm sort of
taking in more of a leadership role in
the field right i sort of certainly
benefit from the resources that we
provide but i'm gathering people i'm
further
sort of i'm sort of deepening my anchor
to the field
and i'm helping pull up younger people
and making sure that trying to make sure
at least that some of the problems that
i dealt with
are
less
effective at pushing people out
or maybe even absent
yeah
very interesting
wow so so i was reading your physics
today commentary um about disentangling
the anti-blackness from physics
and you cited how you know you were one
of roughly 25 black men in yale grad
school at the time 2015.
so but you also just now you talked
about
meeting other like-minded people and
energized you and
gave you confidence and conviction so
so i'm curious how you kind of
transitioned and you know got inspired
to actually reaching out and to build a
community
um
and
what kind of advice you would have for
you know current students who may have
similar experiences in
in grad school um there may be in
physics um or other um science area
and and how
like what what advice and you know how
how can they also learn to build
community and leverage each other
so yeah that's that's an excellent
question incredibly important for
students and really for
really for everyone
uh and it happens to turn out that some
of us in particular ethnic minorities or
gender minorities or other
underrepresented folks on on campus
don't always find themselves in
communities in the way that more
represented people do sort of
automatically and so
i took it
i made a point to build community out of
necessity because i didn't have it and i
didn't initially realize the importance
of it
and it really became clear that i needed
to be able to talk to other people about
my experiences
people that sort of
automatically understood my experiences
definitely people who i could talk to
that like didn't hold preconceived
notions say of my like intellectual
ability it really could take me for face
at face value and respect me fully as a
human
with an educated one uh
that has lots of useful and important
thoughts to contribute and so my first
sort of major goal at this at yale was
the formation of the yale league of
black scientists so this was a student
group that i formed with two other iel
graduates um
one is my wife lindsay mcmillan-brown
who i believe is in the audience she uh
got her phd in chemical engineering uh a
little bit before me i can't remember
when anymore uh but then also brooke
russell who
um got her phd from you know physics and
she was the first black woman to get her
phd from now physics uh she was in my
cohort so yeah we started this group and
and it was
great because it was a mechanism
through which we can apply for funds in
the university through the very nice
student group system at yale uh in order
to like create programming that can
support black stem phd students
um you know that could be like sort of
professional development which we did or
also even social events
because
you know a lot of the black students at
yale were in the humanities and social
sciences and they're on a different part
of campus and so as a grad student it's
easy to be isolated and if you're a
black stem phd student i mean the
combination of being physically far away
from other black students and there
being few black student phd students
mean it's very very easy for you to be
alone
and so yelling to black scientists was a
mechanism to produce
programming that sort of supported our
professional development as
uh phd students as black ones uh that
helped us socialize with each other and
that kept us engaged in the local
community so another thing we did was we
got very engaged with the um
the pathways to science office just sort
of attached to the main outreach arm of
yale and we were everywhere around the
city we were in local schools and we
were interacting with kids from local
schools here or not here i'm not in yale
but on the yale campus
and that was actually really important
part of
providing anchors for us that sort of
work made it clear that our presence
there was important and that we were
making important changes
and so
this is sort of long-winded but
i can say that community is super
important and everyone needs community
some people sort of get it for free and
it tends to be the case that
underrepresented people have to work for
it or even build it because in many
cases it doesn't already exist
and so one good way for students to
find community is to well go around and
look for the resources that exist yale
has many excellent resources especially
for students um and if you find
something that you need doesn't exist
build it and they're you know i found
that there were many people both in the
physics department or higher up
including dean cooley who supported the
league of black scientists and try to
make sure that we have the resources we
needed to support ourselves
um
this also means going and talking with
people leaning on people
being authentic and real about your
experiences i mean you know being a
yell students are strong students who
have histories of being strong students
and sometimes go to yell and have a hard
time and can have a hard time
being honest about having a hard time
but i think in order to make the sort of
connections you need and build a
community you need to really thrive as a
human you need to be open with other
people reach out um and let it be known
that it's okay to sort of struggle with
things
um and so that may involve going and
having you know real maybe even
heartfelt conversations with your peers
or reaching out to faculty that's
something that i did a lot i was
fortunate to have a fantastic phd
advisor who i spoke to about everything
i was lucky to have that but there are
other people
on the yale physics faculty that were
incredible mentors for me that i reached
out to about my issues and they
supported me in the way that they could
and so that was another way of building
community so my message to students
would be identify the faculty that care
about you there will be several uh and
they are well-resourced uh influential
and powerful people that can make
very serious changes in your life for
the better
wow
okay thank you for sharing i like yeah
what you said being authentic
uh be authentic about
our
um
our hardship sometimes um be willing to
open up and and also to seek out and
yeah i think
like i was also um
in a way a minority when i was there and
i um
i mean i didn't know better so i was
i yeah i was speaking out and seeking
out help so so it it's great that you
know you've had a great support system i
mean in a way you build it yourself you
reach out to your advisor to other
faculties
and to
fellow students in even
in the humanities
that that's that's right absolutely and
actually if i could add i'll say that um
our friends so you know i'm speaking as
a physicist i would say our friends on
the humanities and social sciences side
have been incredibly important to me um
in a way that i couldn't have known
would be true before i got to yale and i
had the privilege of interacting with so
many of them they gave me so many tools
to sort of contextualize my experience
as a human it gave me language to talk
about important issues and so you know i
would i would have been worse off if i
did not have the fortune of interacting
with so many people on the humanities
and social science side i just want to
add that very important very important
thank you really appreciate your
candidness about all of this charles and
that vulnerability that i think a lot of
students um will uh
empathize with and sympathize with um
and also i i just really commend you on
the ways in which you were able during
your time at yale to reach out to so
many communities you were talking a bit
about community
but the ways in which you created your
well you reached out to the scholarly
communities the national society of
black physicists and others but also
your department beyond your department
the graduate school community but even
the new haven community talking about
the pathways program which is so
wonderful
um and i i think you're a model of what
we hope graduate students will do and to
re-emphasize that the dean's office is
here to support students in that way
it's so wonderful to hear stories of
students really taking advantage of all
there is to get out of this place
um and you've referred a couple of times
to um mentorship and you even mentioned
mcerie who i believe is on the call
tonight um and i wanted to ask you a
little bit specifically because on the
one hand there is the building of
communities
but also um i want to ask you about how
you found mentors um and we talked a lot
about sort of peers and finding your
peers but finding good faculty members
both as a graduate student um and now as
a postdoc you know as you grow in your
own career how have your thoughts about
mentorship evolved and how you see
yourself as a mentor and can you speak a
little bit to that yeah so uh yeah let
me first say that
uh
unequivocally mentorship is incredibly
important and it's important for
everyone and again
it turns out to be the case that
um while mentorship is important for
everyone
it's often that underrepresented
minorities don't find themselves in the
sort of important mentorship
relationship that they need to
um to to thrive in a way that
more represented groups do
uh some of which sort of get it for free
even
um so how did i uh
how did i end up you know having strong
mentors
it came it was born out of me being
authentic and me asking for help me
describing the issues that i was having
and seeking
people that
sort of
could understand what i was trying to
describe
didn't necessarily have preconceived
notions of
my
i don't know my background my ability
wouldn't necessarily be like oh you know
you're just being sensitive
that's not real or
you know
that that really listened to me and i
think i was i was fortunate to get in in
a number of ways
i mentioned that i had a great phd
advisor um and that was really important
to my experience and not i think not all
students are as fortunate to have such a
great advisor my my phd advisor is not
only a fantastic scientist but he's
someone that like obviously very much
cares about the people that work in his
group and he was very open to learning a
lot about my experience throughout my
time and he made it clear that i could
be open with him
about the difficulties that i was having
and i did this with other faculty
i already mentioned meg i was a teaching
fellow for meg
for definitely one semester and we were
having a conversation about
uh women in physics and i think i said
something like okay well if you think
about if you think this about women in
physics what do you think about black
people in physics and that turned into
like a five-hour conversation in her
office but i pretty much just unloaded
all of my difficulties on meg and she
listened and she gave me lots of
resources she
made it happen that i went to the
national society of black physicist
conference and had this life-changing
experience
so for me
um
gaining mentors has again been being
authentic about the difficulties that
i'm having and asking for help and not
necessarily being stuck on having
mentors that look exactly like me
i'm i would be the first one to tell you
that role models are incredibly
important and so for that reason yale
should continue his work
more even more aggressively to say
diversify the faculty because i think
it's important for students like people
who uh share my identity for example to
see a role model that looks like that
however in the current landscape
students and really everybody at all
levels they need to be able to identify
what they need and find mentors that
speak to different aspects of their
personality or that can provide
different resources and so you know
what was the case for me in my time at
yale and even now is me
finding multiple mentors that speak to
different parts of my identity a
physicist and have a human and together
i sort of have all of my needs fulfilled
by this sort of network of mentorship
and i think that that's a really
important lesson for students go and
find people that care about you that can
speak to different parts of your
identity um and that will serve you
incredibly well
and again i keep saying students but
it's not just students like you still
need mentorship if you're a postdoc you
still need mentorship if you're a junior
faculty member even if you're a full
professor i mean you're going to be
engaging in things where there is some
more experienced person that's not
necessarily older than you but that can
help guide you through a process where
guiding is very necessary this is sort
of always the case so i think that
message is is important really for
everybody
i often tell graduate students in fact
that um yale is just made up of people
and that's how you sort of have to
navigate this place you can't just talk
about yale as an entity
on its own but it's actually made up of
individuals and sounds like you've met
many of them who have helped you in your
career and now you're helping as an alum
so we appreciate that yeah absolutely
i did did i so i knew that that was a
multi-part question did i answer all the
parts of that question
yeah i think i think we hit on some
topics and we'll there'll be more there
are some questions coming through on the
chat i'll also put a plug in now to
please continue submitting questions to
the q a um but um i'll pass it over to
john for the next one
thank you matthew um
so
see i was wondering you know now charles
you're an alum now so
maybe you're already offering some help
and advice to
students fellow students and fix
today
the other question is you kind of touch
the
at the end of your
last
topic
um
i'm combining this with you know a
question from stephanie
right i mean it takes a lot of
initiative to build that network of the
infrastructure the support system
now
what kind of advice you have
from
sort of an institution level an
educational institution level um what
changes we need to put in place what
kind of developments
um like what additional infrastructure
we should help to facilitate
to make this easier for
for all students to be to be inclusive
for them easy to to find the support
they need
yeah so i think that
i think that uh so to me uh and really
important part of this is
diversifying at different levels
so one thing that i think is really
great that the physics department has
achieved recently is really increasing
the amount of women in the park if i
remember this i heard that this the most
or the last incoming graduate school
class
was
uh maybe majority women maybe 55 women
or something and that's really special
for a department that
for a long time hadn't had very many
women and that's important because
you know it's more so the case that
women new women who are students can go
in and see themselves represented they
have more people that can speak to
their identity that sort of understands
some of the struggles that they go
through there's already sort of a
foundation for community and that same
kind of thing is important for example
for black people say me for black men
right and so i think at multiple levels
if
we could have
uh so let me just use this as an example
because i i think about physics
i and and let me use my identity as an
example
what i'm saying is we need to have more
black undergraduate graduates in the
physics department and so that means we
need to
improve our recruitment efforts we need
to have more black graduate students in
the physics department and so
we need to improve our recruitment
efforts we need to have
black postdocs in the physics department
and so we need to improve our
recruitment efforts and the same is true
for faculty and i think
like if you can pull
several
uh individuals that represent these
different identities um into the
department again there's already a
foundation for
uh community and it will start to
change
um
sort of department norms and then i feel
like you're getting into a
situation where it starts to become more
practical
or at least easier to sort of change the
the climate to change the environment
right when you when you're able to
uh change norms based off of having
these different groups needs met
in a way that's policy based and
actually enforced then you can start to
really
i think you can start to really
create an environment where people can
sort of leave baggage at the door right
so in physics a lot of physicists will
tell you like oh you know physics should
be apolitical right uh
blah blah blah but like physics science
it's all human endeavors there's so much
so many aspects of our humanity so many
aspects of society that creep in the
door and that includes things like bias
and so if you're changing norms and
policies in your department that sort of
really can leave bias at the door then
you can have something like you know
more physics interactions right in a way
that uh
really allows people to thrive so i
think i'm always going to say that
uh we need to change norms and policies
along with
bringing more underrepresented groups in
so that they can uh
have the climate they need to be
respected and supported but then also
make sure that these people have
resources that they need which are going
to be different for students or postdocs
or faculty
and i think that that's a in my mind
that's a very clear way to
um
really
uh steer the trajectory of the academy
as a whole in the right direction
thank you charles
thank you yeah a lot to think about how
to
enhance the pipeline and then
um
really recruit
diverse candidates
through all phases of institution so
thank you which also might mean bringing
them in in clusters and again you know
uh
there are lots of resources there are
lots of examples of where these people
are
there are other things that get in the
way of bringing them in so we need to we
need to sort of
uh attack the problem more head-on and
bring in a lot of the talented people
that are known to exist like they
definitely exist we need to bring them
in and change the climate
um and make sure that they have the
support and respect and resources that
they that they that they need
you're uh
oops sorry jack
[Music]
um your your response made me think of
one of the questions that was actually
submitted in advance um so i think i'll
just ask that real quick um and we'll
sort of pivot to the q a from the
attendees and so someone had submitted a
question that reads what two things
would you say to a urm student who is
considering but unsure about whether to
pursue a postgraduate degree in science
and or physics and why should they do it
i think it's a really interesting
question
yeah um so
um
okay so one thing that i i sort of
time and time again come across
with
my conversations with underrepresented
students
is
concerned with paying for stem grad
school
and so
what's really important for these
students to know is that in almost all
cases a stem phd will be funded so that
you will have a stipend that will
support you paying for living expenses
food and rent it sort of depends on
where you live whether or not that
compensation is enough right there are
many examples around the country where
students are working hard to have higher
compensation to address
um issues with cost of living for
example in the bay area where cost of
living can be very very high
but underrepresented students need to
know that stem phds are funded
that's an important consideration for i
think many underrepresented students it
certainly was for me as someone who
you know came from humble beginnings and
certainly would be concerned about
say taking out
tens and tens of thousands of dollars in
student loans in order to pay for my
education
um i think another reason to
yeah i think another important reason to
consider doing a stem phd is that in our
society it being very technologically
driven
i would say
it is clear that more stem education
leads to more
socioeconomic mobility leads to more
opportunities
and again as someone who
not has for a long time not only loved
physics but has
thought it to be important that i can
have a career where i could support
myself and in the future supportive
family
i think you know one should really
consider that if you have passion to do
stem
get
the best and the highest education that
you can because that will really
uh not limit your potential of what sort
of work you can do your earning
potential and the sort of opportunities
generally you will have to move around
and have different sorts of jobs maybe
doing hands-on science or maybe maybe
doing some leadership work leading
leading teams of sciences
scientists
so
i think those are the two things that
sort of
most quickly come to mind it's that
these stem programs tend to be funded
and that having a large amount of stem
education will give you
lots of economic mobility in our society
i think those are great pieces of advice
and definitely the funding
piece is something we we try to talk
about a lot during recruitment um i
think it's an
unknown fact but um we try and tell it
to the world
um
and i want to pick up on one other thing
that you said you have this conviction
and it's actually come up a few times
about um how you've always sort of known
that you wanted to be a physicist
um and another question that we received
um
it's given the scarcity of role models
can you speak to the moment you became
aware that you could become a physicist
[Music]
yeah that is such an interesting
question so
i feel like i can answer that in a
number of ways that aren't exactly
consistent with each other so let me try
to give a bit of context to
to what i might say
in a sense i wanted to be a physicist
for my entire life long before i
actually knew what that was
um i was fortunate to
have in my mother a role model who
really loved science who wasn't a
scientist herself but loved science
loved to talk to me about science and so
that got me interested in science very
early
and
so i've been sort of thinking about
science and dreaming of being a
scientist for a long time even though i
didn't have any role models around me
that were scientists nor did i interact
with any scientist until i got to
undergraduate
until i got to
university
okay so there's one answer the other
answer is
maybe when i was in grad school and i
went to the national society of black
business conference and i for the first
time was in a room full of many kinds of
black scientists physicists
or physics adjacent people in
engineering or chemistry or
biological physics who had very very
wide backgrounds very wide experiences
some similar to mine some very different
but who all were in the same room
talking about foods
working in different universities or
government labs or industry
and so
that was a very sort of
um
like
self-image reaffirming experience you
know like i've had this i've had this
film for a long time like yeah i want to
be a physicist i you know i used to love
albert einstein he used to love to read
about his work and read about black
holes and sort of it was this sort of
abstract thing and then i see all these
physicists i'm like wow okay this is
this is really a thing now you know um
so
those those are my answers
those are my answers
i think those are great i i
so
this is a completely personal question
but um
so how did that get into your specific
interests and i'm not going to try and
restate what you said at the beginning
about your specific work in graduate
school but about light um which sort of
drew my attention um i was really
intrigued by the that topic and the way
that you were describing what it can do
with certain materials but um was there
a sort of pathway that led you and i
suppose part of the way in which i'm
framing this i could ask the question of
like why did you choose yale and like
what brought you here and how did you
get interested in the specifics of the
work that you were doing here
yeah so
you know when i first started college i
was actually an engineering major and i
quickly realized that
it was i needed to change my path
because it was the how things
uh worked that was the thing that sort
of drew me the most that i was most
passionate about
um
now with that i sort of have always been
interested in the foundations right i
like to think of myself as an
investigator as a sort of detective in a
sense uh but instead of solving murders
i'm trying to solve mysteries of the
universe and i happen to do so through
experiments i used to want to do so
theoretically and so that has led to my
interest in the foundations of of how
things work so when i got to the
university of minnesota where i got my
bachelor's degree and i took my first
quantum physics class i had a great
teacher his name is uh
jim cacallios he's a condensed matter
experimentalist that works on different
kinds of uh devices
but he uh he also cares a lot about
cycom he wrote a popular science book
called the physics of superheroes so
that already sort of tells you that he's
developed his ability to talk about
science in an engaging way and he taught
my quantum class and after that i was
completely hooked i felt like i have to
be thinking about quantum mechanics and
quantum physics for the rest of my life
after taking his class and so i had a
research experience with him so i was
fortunate to get in his lab i had a
summer research experience funded by the
nsf in their research experience for
undergraduate program where i got to go
to uchicago for a summer and do some
quantum related research um i did an
honors senior a senior honors thesis
where i got to do other kind of
materials quantum research and so when
it was time for me to go to grad school
i was completely sold that i was going
to do some sort of material physics
thing
um but
uh in my process of searching for a
potential phd advisor in grad school i
came across jack harris who was my phd
advisor and
um
i thought his work was incredible that
was incredibly interesting i think you
know when you come in as a graduate
student you're really wide-eyed and you
think everything is amazing and it's
because everything is right yale faculty
and other faculty elsewhere do lots of
very interesting science but i was
convinced that uh the person who became
my phd advisor's work was incredibly
interesting now a funny thing here is
that uh i ended up working on something
completely different in his group right
i had this opportunity to switch away
from doing material physics stuff to
thinking about this you know uh light
interacting with matter thinking about
quantum mechanics thinking about how big
a quantum system can be which like
really
fulfilled my desire to think about
foundations of physics like deep deep
things about why things are the way they
are and what they can be
um and so that's sort of what set me on
the quantum physics trajectory
i love that combination of sort of
breadth and depth that as you sort of
continue going for the fundamentals you
were also sort of
trying out all of these different ways
in which they could come to bear
that's great
um so
we've sort of touched on this broadly
but there's a question that's very
specific
to physics and it's what are some of the
challenges in your opinion that black
underrepresented students and scientists
face in navigating the field
so thinking really specifically about
physics
are there particular things that you
think um black students and scientists
are facing
yeah i think one of the biggest things
is perceptions of ability
so
um unfortunately
there you know many aspects of society
tend to want to force black people in
particular into a certain box
and that box does not include attributes
like smart
and
that
that is a very real thing that you feel
immediately when you walk into an
environment like yale where intelligence
is sort of a currency right well that's
one of the main ways by which you
evaluate a peer or
a near peer or
someone you either outrank or who
outranks you
and so
certainly
perceived intelligence or perceived
incompetence is a is a difficulty
it also turns out that
race class social economic status are
sort of all wound up
uh in the united states
and it also turns out that
that can mean that for some students
some underrepresented some black
students
they could come up in an educational
system that lacked important resources
um and so
i think what that means is
sometimes
i want to be really careful about how i
say this
i think that means that sometimes
students can
uh
find that they have different
preparation than other students and
sometimes they're not in teaching
environments where
the teaching is sort of
cognizant of that fact
right so sometimes you end up in a
classroom where students have different
preparations it's not always the case
that the teaching is geared towards sort
of meeting people where they are and
building them up sometimes teaching can
speak to only the students who have had
the most resources that come from the
most well-funded school districts right
that have the wealthy people who can pay
the taxes which then go and fund the
schools that give some students all
these extra resources compared to other
students and that leads to differences
in in preparation
when going to next steps
um that's an issue that's a sort of
bigger one that's a society-wide that's
a funding that's a how do we
you know
yeah that that that's a tough one but
that's important um and then again i've
already mentioned but
but community right again it's easy to
come into a situation where you were the
only person right for
over a decade i have almost always been
the only person like me in the room and
it's really hard to
have that identity sometimes because i
can tell you when i was a younger grad
student i was deathly afraid of making a
mistake and convincing everyone around
me that
what people thought about black people
was true
that
if i
was to fail a test for example it would
only suggest that it is indeed the case
that black people cannot be physicists
because you don't see them right and
people already sort of hold these
notions sometimes about us
and so
black students or
lgbtq students or
students with various disabilities can
sometimes carry this weight where they
don't see role models people already
don't think that they belong in the
spaces and it's really hard for them to
feel like they can actually be human and
make mistakes without confirming that
they indeed do not belong
and so that is a huge challenge that you
sort of always face
uh when you're under represented student
um i think maybe i'll stop there i can
keep on going but i should stop
no i definitely
i i appreciate that and the ways in
which we have this complicated
um
situation in graduate school where
there's there is this sort of
the way in which your intelligence
perceived is not always accurate and
then there's also imposter syndrome on
top of that and how those two things
play with one another
and that pressure that so many
underrepresented students feel to
actually be the best right um and all of
that combined creates this stressful
environment so often it's um i really
appreciate you speaking about it so
honestly
um so i think we'll jaw i see put a
question in the chat so maybe we'll
we'll use that as our final question um
which is what is your next move uh
academia industry non-profit are you
thinking about this how are you thinking
about this i think this is a question
that our students are constantly
wondering themselves
yeah so i'm thinking about this a lot
and i've been thinking about it for a
long time um
academia all the way so
um i'm positive that i want to be a
professional physicist i can do so in
academia um i also think that
the university system globally uh is
incredibly important i think it's one of
the most important things that humanity
has done and i really want to take a
part in
being a thought leader in physics and
quantum science but also being part of
the leadership of the university system
again shepherding it into the future
making sure that
uh
the university continues to be a like a
hotbed for the production of knowledge
right this is this is important for just
how we understand our place in the
universe as humans but then also for how
we say produce technology that goes and
enriches lives
and i think it's important for us to do
so in a way that's equitable that is not
uh like increasing or driving
disparities in different people's
experiences doing so in a way that
levels the playing field that enriches
people's lives and i want to take a part
in like making sure the university that
i'm at in the future as a faculty member
and that it uh does that and i want to
sort of take the
the role as a leadership as a uh yeah
the role of a leader and sort of be a
role model as a faculty member maybe for
other faculty members uh regarding
what being an effective faculty member
looks like right i don't believe that
that is just being excellent in science
as a physicist i think it's being
excellent at science
being a good teacher
being a good human that cares about
uh
making sure that
different people from different
backgrounds
uh are in a
you know inclusive space that respects
them as people
that
really provides them with the resources
to to thrive
um so yeah
i'm gonna be a professor and i'm looking
forward to it
it's a fantastic answer thank you so
much and we we need you so uh we
appreciate that that path ahead of you
thank you um i want to thank uh dean
cooley i want to thank charles and ja
for their remarks and this conversation
tonight um and also to all the students
and alumni who joined us thank you for
being here um thanks also to my
colleagues yasmina bashirovich regan and
kathleen gallo for all their hard work
in putting this event together along
with the gsa
um i hope everyone has enjoyed the
conversation and will continue to help
us build a stronger community among
graduate students faculty and alumni so
thank you again especially charles thank
you
um we hope that you'll all join us for
our next event in the perspective series
with lindsay mcmillan-brown
name you might have heard earlier today
who's also class of 2019 phd in chemical
engineering who's working as a research
engineer at the nasa glenn research
center in cleveland and that
conversation will take place on december
8th at 8pm more info will be sent out by
email
i also encourage anyone who has not
already done so to join cross campus or
to log in if you haven't done so in a
little while
across campus as you may know is a
fantastic way for alumni and students to
connect with one another formally or
informally
and if there are other ways in which
you'd like to be more involved in
supporting the graduate school please
don't hesitate to reach out to me and my
colleagues we'd love to hear from you
we look forward to seeing everyone again
soon for our next conversation in the
perspective series thank everyone thank
you everyone and have a good night
thank you thank you